[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Please join me in
welcoming Victoria Turk.
[APPLAUSE]
VICTORIA TURK:
Thank you very much,
and thank you so much
for everyone for coming.
Thanks for inviting me.
It's a real pleasure to be here.
I'm Victoria Turk.
I am an editor at
WIRED UK, and I've also
just written this book,
"Digital Etiquette," which
is out this week.
Before I go any
further, I just wanted
to make a quick
confession, which
is that this is the
very first talk I've
given about this book.
And in fact, it's pretty
much the first talk
I've ever given about anything.
So you guys are my guinea pigs.
And if my knees look
like they're shaking,
it's probably because they are.
[LAUGHS] But
anyway-- oh, also, it
is the first
PowerPoint presentation
I've made since high school.
So I haven't used
any clip art, but I
might have gotten a
little bit carried away
with the animations.
[LAUGHTER]
It's actually a Keynote.
Keynote didn't even exist when
I was at high school, I think.
Anyway--
So what is digital etiquette?
Well, the idea behind this
book was basically a fun,
modern take on the
traditional etiquette guide
for digital communications.
And I think a lot
of people, when
they think about this term,
"etiquette," it sounds very old
fashioned and stuffy.
But actually, I think
it's super important.
It is the social
glue that makes it
possible to communicate
with each other
without accidentally
offending someone.
And we all do it, whether
we realize or not.
And I think it's
especially important online
and in digital communications
for several reasons.
Firstly, because most digital
communications are text based.
That means you're very
limited in terms of the tools
that you have to get
your point across.
You've probably all
had that situation
where you meet someone
only over email,
and you get the impression that
they're very terse and very
brusque and kind of rude,
because their emails are always
really short.
But then you meet
them in person,
and they're absolutely
lovely and really nice.
So I think for that reason,
digital communications
can be full of
particular pitfalls
when it comes to etiquette.
Also, they're obviously
rarely truly private.
Even if you think you're
just talking to one person,
your conversation could
easily be shared more widely.
And they leave a digital trail.
So that angry email you
send at 3:00 in the morning
is going to be in
someone else's inbox
forever once you've sent it.
So this is a saying
you've probably heard.
"On the internet, no
one knows you're a dog--
but that's no excuse
for poor manners."
Now, the book covers
four different chapters,
each of which is dedicated
to a different sphere
of modern life.
So there's the
workplace, romance--
which is obviously a
lot of online dating--
friendship, and community,
which is social media.
And it would be
impossible for me
to attempt to cover all
of those here today.
And given that this is, for
most of you, your place of work,
I thought we'd focus
on the workplace,
and specifically
on how to do email.
Now, I do realize
the absolute conceit
of me coming into
Google and trying
to tell you how to do email.
But the last I checked, you
don't have a Chief Etiquette
Officer.
So maybe I can bring up one
or two points that are of use.
And actually, just to see
what I'm dealing with,
let's start with
a quick question.
Let's talk about
email sign-offs.
I want you to think about
your default email sign-off--
the one you use 90% of the time.
You type it without
even thinking.
Who uses "best wishes"?
Someone over there.
Anyone use "best"
or "all the best"?
Variations on a theme?
Quite a few.
Great.
Who uses anything else?
OK, it's worse than I thought.
[LAUGHS] Because
you guys are wrong.
[LAUGHS]
[LAUGHTER]
But we'll get to email sign-offs
and the details of actually
writing an email later on.
First, I want to step
back a bit and just
think about the bigger
picture of email etiquette.
My driving philosophy
behind email etiquette
comes from one pretty
universal truth.
"Everyone hates email."
Again, maybe not the best
place to be saying this.
[LAUGHS] But I'm sure there's
a few of you out there.
Now, don't get me wrong.
Email is a fantastic innovation.
There's a reason we all
use it and we still use it,
decades after it was invented.
It lets us communicate
with people
on the other side of the
world, in different time zones,
and it's really actually
reshaped workplace culture.
I don't think it would be
possible to work remotely
if we didn't have email.
So it is a really great
thing, and it is often
very convenient.
However, it's also stressful,
time consuming, annoying,
and it often feels
like it no longer just
helps us to do work--
it actually is work.
You don't see many job
ads where in the listing,
they put skills required,
"being really good at email."
And yet, I've spent
whole days in my inbox,
just writing and
responding to emails.
Now, I don't think anyone really
wakes up full of a sense of joy
at the number of unread
messages they've got
in their inbox in the morning.
I think you probably feel
more of a sense of dread.
At least, I hope I'm
not the only one.
In fact, I know I'm not the only
one, because there have been
studies that have shown this.
One of my favorites is
actually a really small study,
but I really liked it,
because they actually
put heart rate monitors on
a bunch of office workers.
And they made them go
about their daily business,
and they tracked
their email usage.
And they found that the
more people spent on email
in a given day, the
more stressed they were,
and the less
productive they felt.
And I think we can probably
all relate to that.
So based on that, given
that email is terrible
and everyone hates
it, the main principle
of good email etiquette is to
reduce it as much as possible.
Every time you
send an email, you
are asking to take up someone
else's time and mental energy.
So obviously, that means
you should only send emails
when you actually need to.
But when you do, you
also want to make sure
that you are making it as easy
as possible for your recipient
to deal with.
You want to make sure you're
including all the information
the first time round, so you're
sending one email and not 10.
And you just want to
make it very clear.
You want to be
concise and precise.
Take up as little
time as possible,
and make it as easy to
deal with as possible.
And often, the best
email is actually
the one you don't send.
So that said, sometimes
you do need to email.
Sometimes it is a good thing.
An email has become,
for many workplaces,
the default means of
communicating-- certainly
in office space workplaces.
That is changing a bit, at least
for internal communications.
I know a lot of offices
use instant messaging tools
like Slack.
I'm sure you guys probably
use Google Hangouts.
I'm getting lots of nods.
Yep.
[LAUGHS]
But certainly for external
communications, and still a lot
of internal communications,
email is king.
It's the thing you just
automatically go to first.
But maybe you shouldn't always,
because the very same things
that make email really
good for some things
make it really bad for others.
So what is email good for?
It's good for
distributing information,
especially if you need
to send a message to lots
of people at once, especially
if it's quite a long message.
Maybe you need to
attach documents.
Perfect.
Simple back-and-forths.
Keep it very simple,
but if you want
to have a quick question-answer,
question-answer with someone,
it can work.
If you have too many people
on a thread or the thread
goes on for too long, it can
very quickly get confused.
So simple is key.
Starting a paper trail.
I think this is
particularly important
if you're working on a
project that you know is going
to take quite a long time.
One really good
thing about email
is it's really easy to search.
It's not so easy to search
back old instant messages
and things like that.
But you can find an old email
from days ago, weeks ago,
months ago, even
years ago very easily.
So great.
But more importantly, what
is email not good for?
It's not good for
immediate responses.
This is actually a bit
of a controversial one,
because I think certainly
today, a lot of people
expect immediate responses
or near-immediate responses
from email.
But going back to the
whole nature of email
in the first place,
the whole point of it
is that it is asynchronous.
So you can send an
email at one time,
and your recipient can pick
it up whenever they like.
You could send it one evening.
They pick it up the
following morning.
That is one of the
major benefits of email.
We'll get onto how fast
you should be expected
to respond soon, but I
do hold that if you're
looking for a really
immediate response,
you shouldn't be
relying on email.
Discussion and debate--
I can't emphasize
enough that email is not
a discursive medium.
I know the one thing people hate
more than email is meetings.
But if you have some
kind of problem,
especially if you need to work
as a group to come together
to create a solution or
come to some conclusion,
email is just a way to
open the miscommunications
in that situation.
So it might be better
just to speak in person.
And nuance-- I mentioned at
the beginning of the talk,
the thing about
digital communications
is it can be very hard to
get your meaning across,
and especially to get any
sense of your emotional meaning
across.
So if it's a situation
that's a bit sensitive,
you probably want to be
choosing a format where
you can use those non-verbal
cues, like tone of voice,
like facial expression,
body language,
to make sure that you're
not misunderstood.
And that's not only to
make sure that you're
coming across the
way you want to,
but also so you can
pick up on those cues
from the other person
you're dealing with,
and maybe tune your
response along the way.
So you've decided that you
do need to send an email
and that email is
definitely the best medium.
A key thing around email
etiquette is timing--
when to send an email.
So obviously, I mentioned
that email is asynchronous,
and that you
shouldn't be expecting
an immediate response.
Expectations have changed hugely
over the past decade because
of smartphones.
It's a pretty obvious point.
It used to be that when you
left the office at night,
you'd leave your
computer, and you
wouldn't be expected
to check your email
until the next morning.
In fact, you probably couldn't.
You couldn't even be
tempted to, because you
had no means of doing so.
Now, we've come
to expect everyone
to carry these mini
computers in their pockets,
and we expect them to
to be available 24/7.
And this has really blurred
the lines between work life
and personal life.
To the extent,
actually, that France
recently brought in a new law
called the [SPEAKING FRENCH]..
It's the "right to disconnect."
And it essentially
enshrines in law
your right to ignore your
boss's email on the weekend.
Because they recognize
that work life was just
impinging on personal
and family life,
so that workers could
never switch off.
And I think if you
wouldn't expect someone
to be in the office
that late working,
you shouldn't expect
them to be checking
their email that late working.
It takes just as
much effort to do so.
So I really think
that you should stick
to work hours or nearabout.
None of us are perfect.
Maybe an hour or so either side.
But try and stick to work hours.
And try, if you want
to be extra good,
and stick to your
recipient's work hours,
especially if they're in
a different time zone.
Now, you might
say, that's great.
I totally respect my colleague's
right to have a personal life
and to not check their
emails in the evening.
But I, the super
conscientious worker--
I really like sending
emails late at night.
I actually enjoy it.
And that way, I'm not
keeping anyone waiting.
They've got their answer
as soon as they want it,
and I feel good about myself.
I can take it off my
to-do list and I'm done.
The problem is, that goes
back to the original paradox
of email--
that you were enjoying
the convenience
of being able to
send it at anytime,
but you're putting the
stress on your recipient.
Because even if you don't expect
them to respond immediately,
they're going to feel
that unread email guilt,
and they're going to be
unsure about whether they're
supposed to be replying
right then or not.
So the onus is on
you as a sender
to set a reasonable norm.
And if you really want to be
answering your emails late,
you can also use the
delay send function,
so you can just schedule it
to email the next morning.
Which brings us to, how fast
must you respond to email?
And this is obviously
the first thing
that comes up whenever I bring
up the idea of email etiquette
with people.
And what's really
funny is that people
have completely
different views on this.
And I think this is one of the
main things that contributes
to email stress in
the first place,
is that we don't have an
agreed consensus on what
we're supposed to be doing.
So we're all just
scrabbling around trying
to please everyone,
and no one knows what
they're supposed to be doing.
Now, it's easy to
say good etiquette is
to respond to an email
as fast as possible.
Usually if someone's emailed
to ask you something,
they want a fast response.
But it obviously is just
so context-dependent.
It could be something
really simple
that you can respond
to right away,
or it could be something
that actually requires
quite a lot of work, and that
you might not be expected
to respond for several days.
So it's a bit of a
cop out answer here.
There is no "one size fits all."
But there is a work
around-- a cheat.
Ask them.
[LAUGHS]
I think a lot of people
assume that etiquette
has to be this unspoken thing--
a secret code that everyone
else but you knows.
But I very much pro
being transparent
and being very practical.
So if you receive
a message and you
don't know what you're
expected to do with it,
just send a quick line back.
Say, hi.
Is it OK if I get back
to you in this by Friday?
Or, hey, this is going
to take me some work.
When do you need it by?
Easy.
And fast replies are actually
not always the best etiquette.
I think a good
example of this is
if you're on an email which has
been sent to a group of people.
Say it's been sent
to your whole team.
I used to be this person who,
at the beginning of my career,
I really wanted to show how keen
I was, and how ready to work
and eager I was to get
involved with everything.
So if our boss
would send an email
to the whole team
asking for input,
I'd immediately jump
in with my two cents.
And I thought I was just
sharing how great I was--
what a good worker.
Actually, obviously, I was
just being super annoying.
I think in that situation,
it's much better etiquette
to sit back, wait awhile,
see what other people say,
see if your input
is even needed,
and if it is, when
you do respond,
you've then got all the
information that you need.
And I think not only
is that good etiquette,
but there's actually
a lot of power
in being able to do
that, and give one
very well-informed response.
"How to write an email."
I promise I'm not
patronizing you guys.
[LAUGHS] I honestly think
this is really hard.
I get it wrong all the time.
I think everyone
gets it wrong a lot.
Everything, of course,
goes back to thinking
about your recipient, and
reducing the burden of email
on them.
So precision and concision
are both your friends.
And this is a quote
from Merlin Mann.
Does anyone know who he is?
He's a speaker, a
podcaster, a writer,
and he coined the
term "inbox zero."
Have you guys head
of inbox zero?
OK, quite a lot of
recognition there.
That's good.
I won't go through
exactly what inbox zero is
in this presentation,
but it's basically
a way to stay on
top of your email
so that you don't drown
in unread messages.
I'm a huge devotee
to inbox zero.
Anyway, Merlin was kind enough
to speak to me for this book.
And this is one thing he
said, which I think really,
really makes a good point when
you're going to write an email.
So he says, "Assume
that everyone
you're communicating
with is smarter than you
and cares more than you
and is busier than you."
Sounds kind of obvious, but
I feel like we all almost
automatically do the opposite.
You think, this is
really important.
Why haven't they responded?
And obviously, it's better to
just consider the other person.
So writing an email--
let's start from the top.
Subject lines.
Pretty simple.
Keep it descriptive.
Again, you're trying
to make your email
super easy to deal with.
So you need something that
helps people categorize it,
and so they can see at a glance
what it's going to be about
and what probably the
adaptations on them
are going to be.
I've got a few examples
of how not to do it.
And I've used a
scenario that I think
everyone who works in an
office will be familiar with.
So here's that email.
"Hi all, Please can
everyone remember
that if you use a
mug from the kitchen
it is your responsibility
to wash it up."
Has anyone ever received
an email like that?
Yeah.
Now you'll notice,
in this email,
there is no subject line.
The subject line
has been left blank.
Don't do that.
It's super annoying.
When you go to check
your email, you just
see who it's sent from,
and there's no subject,
and you immediately
assume the worst, right?
You're like, oh, god.
I'm in trouble.
You could argue you're in
trouble there, but yeah.
So don't do that.
Don't put the whole message
in the subject line.
I've seen people do this.
I often see, actually,
quite senior people
have a habit of doing this.
And again, it's super
annoying, especially
if you check your
email on mobile.
You only get the
first few words.
It's like, what am I supposed
to be doing with that?
The click bait headline.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, I've seen quite a
few of these in my time,
usually from PRs trying
to get my attention.
Yeah, obviously it's
just misleading.
It's not very useful.
And you probably think
you're being really funny,
but you're not.
Oh, here.
URGENT-- kitchen mess.
[LAUGHS]
Yeah, so it's OK to play the
urgent card every now and then,
if it truly is urgent-- if
you need a fast response.
But every time you play that
card, you are devaluing it.
I don't think many
people would consider
this an actual emergency.
So be very judicious
with "urgent."
I'm going back to the whole
point of email etiquette
as well.
If it wasn't at least a
bit important, (HUSHED)
you probably
shouldn't be sending
the email in the first place.
(NORMALLY) So yeah-- so
this is what I've gone for--
kitchen mess.
Yeah, it's totally
boring, completely bland,
and therefore,
absolutely perfect
for a professional situation.
Subject lines-- how
to start the email.
This is pretty easy, so I
won't spend too long on that.
You don't need to greet
someone every time, especially
if you have a
back-and-forth thread.
So obviously, you
might first say hi.
But it's like if you were
having a conversation.
If you're having a quick
back-and-forth email thread,
you wouldn't say "Hi.
How are you?"
"Hi.
I'm great."
That's good."
"Hi.
And what about yourself?"
Yeah.
Good too, thanks."
You just wouldn't do
that, and you don't
have to do it on email, either.
Once you've established the
back-and-forth conversation,
fine to omit it.
I usually just, as a rule of
thumb, if a day has passed,
so you slept on it, I'll
then do a greeting again.
"Dear Someone" is not
usually necessary,
unless the email is taking
the place of a formal letter.
So if it's a cover letter
for a job application
or an official
invitation of some sort,
then you might
want to use "dear."
It's 2019.
You can probably use
someone's first name.
The exception I
make is if they have
a title that is
not Ms., Mr., Miss,
Mrs. So if it's something like
Doctor, Professor, Lord, Lady,
Madame, Sir, I would use the
title the first time round,
just because some people
are quite picky about that.
And then when they
respond, they'll
probably sign off
with their first name.
You're on a first-name basis.
That's fine.
But "dear" not
usually necessary.
"Hi" is probably fine.
Striking the right tone--
I mentioned several
times already that this
is truly difficult. Email is
terrible for communicating
emotion.
For this reason, I actually am
totally pro things like emoji,
using lots of
exclamation marks--
whatever it is that helps you to
express your emotional meaning
and get your view
across more clearly,
I think is totally fine.
Obviously, that's going to be a
bit dependent on where you work
and what your position is.
If you're a lawyer, smiley
faces might not be appropriate.
But in the media world,
usually totally fine.
So anything that you can do
to be clear is a good thing.
And again, striking
the right tone
is going to depend
a lot on context.
So you do have to make a
lot of judgment calls there.
But there are a few
stereotypical ways that people
email that I've observed.
And I think that
everyone in this room
will probably be
able to recognize
at least one person they
know who does each of these.
The boss emailer.
So this is the concept
of emailing like a CEO.
And Katie Notopoulos--
American digital journalist.
She wrote this great piece
about "emailing like a CEO."
What is that?
It's when you respond right
away, but just with one or two
words.
Like just, "OK."
And she noticed that
her boss did this,
and it's also a thing
that a lot of tech CEOs
are quite well known for.
You probably know
Amazon's Jeff Bezos.
He's renowned for
forwarding emails
from customers to Amazon staff
with not even a word-- just
a character.
A question mark.
Can you imagine receiving that?
The horror.
[LAUGHS] So yeah,
emailing like a CEO.
I spoke to Katie about this,
because she did an experiment
where she tried it for a week.
And she said it was
actually really great.
It made her feel so
much more productive.
She really stayed
on top of things.
And she told me,
she'd never realized
before how much email hung over
her like a little black cloud.
So it definitely
has its advantages.
It helps you be able to
maintain your inbox zero,
if that's what you're
working towards.
But you have to
exercise caution,
because there's a very fine line
between being concise and being
brusque, and being
brusque and being rude.
So it's a really
difficult one to judge.
And there's a certain
thing to be said
about who is able to do this.
It's called "emailing
like a CEO,"
and it tends to be people in
senior positions who do it.
And when you get higher
up the pecking order,
maybe you have a
bit more license
to actually just be a bit rude.
So it really depends where you
are on whether you can get away
with it or not.
And if you work in something
like customer relations or HR,
there's a certain
expectation on you
that you have to be a bit more
gentle in your email tone.
So that's the boss emailer.
The corporate jargon waffler.
This is almost the opposite
of the boss emailer,
yet they have the
same aspirations.
So this is someone
who sees every email
as an official missive
to be carefully crafted.
They probably read a
lot of business books,
and they're always
into the latest
trends in thought leadership,
and they try and use that
in their writing.
So they end up with things
like this sort of stuff.
You can probably
tell from this, I've
never actually worked in a
really corporate environment.
But my partner who's a
management consultant
tells me that it is
not that far off.
So yeah, you've probably
all received something
like that, which
means obviously,
absolutely nothing at all.
Definitely one to avoid.
Third type of emailer--
[LAUGHS] I couldn't think
of a name for this one,
and that's the best thing
I could come up with
to describe it.
And I now realize obviously,
that headline right
next to me, and
probably everyone
could just take a picture
and put it on social media.
But that would obviously be
terrible digital etiquette,
so I'm sure you
wouldn't do that.
But yeah, so this I think
is actually really--
it's a big phenomenon.
And I think I have
definitely been guilty
of this in the past.
I'm sure I will be guilty
of doing it in the future.
I think it's actually
a very British thing
where, especially if
you get a little bit
annoyed or a little bit worked
up, instead of being rude,
you go overly formal in a
way that looks ostensibly
polite, but is actually just
super passive-aggressive.
So instead of saying
something like, "can you
get back to me soon?"
Perfectly normal and acceptable.
You'd say something like, "I
would be much obliged if you
could kindly respond to this
message at your earliest
convenience."
Yeah.
Has anyone ever done that?
We've got a few people
confessing that one.
[LAUGHTER]
So that's another
one to be aware of.
Before we move on, a few
common email translations.
I find it really funny that
we will have these set phrases
that we seem to use in email,
and we wouldn't consider
saying them anywhere else.
It's just that kind
of email language.
And I think it's
especially funny
when I see the Gmail
suggested automated responses,
because they're
always so spot on.
Because we all already
just email like robots.
So we'll just through for a few.
"Apologies for the
delayed response."
Yeah, it's just the law that
you have to start messages
with that, I think.
I've tried not to.
My hands just do it.
"Hope you're well!"
Yeah, there's really no need
to ask after someone's health,
unless you have a
reason to be concerned.
We all know this is inauthentic,
and you don't actually
want to know.
"Not sure if you saw
my last message."
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
You definitely saw
my last message.
Obviously, what you mean with
that is hey, why haven't you
responded?
"Just following up."
Yeah, we're always "just
following up," aren't we?
No. you're never
just following up.
If you're just following up,
why are you sending the email?
Just ask the question that
you need to be answered.
"Does that make sense?"
[LAUGHTER]
Of course it makes sense.
You wouldn't be sending the
email if it didn't make sense.
If you would, you need to go
back and start redrafting.
"Thanks in advance."
I'm going to talk about
thanks in advance a bit more
in the next slide.
But yeah, obviously it's the--
again, going back to that
passive-aggressive thing.
It doesn't really mean what
it seems to on the surface.
So back to what I asked at the
beginning and email sign-offs.
These are the ones I'll accept.
Basically, "best wishes"
or any variations on them.
Why do I think they're
a good email sign-off?
They're inoffensive.
They're formal enough
without being overly formal.
They're totally
boring, again, which
makes them just perfect
for at least 90%
of workplace communications.
You're not going to offend
anyone with the "best wishes."
What do I not like?
AUDIENCE: Ooh.
VICTORIA TURK: Has
anyone seen that one?
I've seen that in the wild.
[LAUGHS] You've obviously taken
a perfectly good sign-off,
"best wishes," and turned it
into an utter abomination.
"Kind regards."
A lot of people use this one.
Does anyone use "kind regards?"
You can admit it.
We've got one over there.
Yeah.
Yeah, we've got a few.
It's fine.
It's probably OK.
I
Just think it's a bit overly
formal for most situations
in the modern workplace.
And I think when you do that
and you go a bit too formal,
it can come off as
standoffish and a bit stuffy.
And it's maybe not
giving the impression
that you quite want to give.
"Cheers."
I use "cheers" all the
time with my colleagues
that I'm also
friends with, and I
think that's fine in
an informal situation.
But as your default sign-off,
it's probably not appropriate.
It's a little bit too informal.
So it's just striking
that balance.
"Thanks in advance" again.
This is-- and I've saved
the worst for last,
because I really hate
"thanks in advance."
Why do I hate it so much?
Because it's-- [EXHALING] sorry.
Just let me gather my thoughts.
OK.
So it's just so presumptuous,
because that's not
how gratitude works.
You don't thank
someone before they've
agreed to do something, right?
It's just saying, oh, yeah.
You realize that you have no
way of getting out of this?
So yeah, I hate
"thanks in advance."
Definitely one to avoid.
Thank someone after
doing something.
[EXHALING]
All right.
So email sign-offs.
Great.
So we've gone
through pretty much
all the main parts
of doing an email,
so you're ready to send it.
One last thing-- and
actually, I think this is--
if you take one thing from
this talk, let it be this.
Let's all agree on
how to use "CC."
[LAUGHTER]
I'm serious.
So when should you
CC on an email?
So obviously this is
when you're sending
an email to all recipients.
It's a very simple rule.
There is a strict rule for this.
The "To" field is for primary
recipients of an email who
are expected to respond.
The "CC" field is
for people who need
to see the email
for reference only,
and who are not
expected to respond.
Now, I didn't come up with this.
I'm not reinventing the wheel.
Do you know the big
old-fashioned etiquette guide,
"Debrett's"?
The edition I have at
home, it's got two pages
in the whole thing
dedicated to the whole
of digital communications.
That's about the same as it has
for how to address a bishop.
But even it includes
this CC rule.
That's how important it is.
Why is it useful?
You're just making very
clear what your expectations
on your recipients are.
And so that is again, reducing
the burden of email stress
on the world.
If people are on CC, they know
they don't need to respond.
If they're in the To field,
they know they have to.
Obviously, the problem
here is that not everyone
may be aware of this rule.
So what you can do
to help establish
good email hygiene is
if you send an email,
you can just say so.
You can just put
something like, "To those
on CC, no need to respond.
This is just an FYI."
And then you don't end up
in that awkward situation
where you've got people who
you just included as a courtesy
responding and turning it into
this whole thread from hell.
Actually, that's
another point on CC.
When should you
include people on CC?
Obviously the top-level
rule of reducing email--
means you should only include
people when it's necessary.
However, people's feelings
trump that productivity.
So good etiquette means
taking other people
into consideration.
So if you're, for
example, emailing
a whole team of
people, you really
need to include them all.
You can't just
include half of them,
even if not everyone is
on a need-to-know basis.
So I call that "tossing
a courtesy CC."
It's like, eh, I'm including
you, even though I don't really
care.
But yeah, just so no
one feels left out.
CC, however isn't
always a courtesy.
Has anyone ever been
in that position
where someone emails you to ask
you to do something, or maybe
even complain about
something you've done,
and they so thoughtfully
think to CC your boss?
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
That's not a courtesy CC.
[LAUGHS] That should be
avoided at all costs.
It's not even
passive-aggressive.
It's just aggressive.
And the thing is,
if you genuinely
need to complain
about someone, you
should be going through the
correct channels, right?
You shouldn't be doing the
snide CC your superiors.
It's like blackmail.
It's like saying, if you
don't respond to this email
how I want you to, you're
going to be in trouble.
So don't do that.
Now, there is, of course,
an alternative to CC--
BCC.
It stands for "blind carbon
copy," as you all know.
So if you send an
email to someone
and include someone on BCC,
your original recipient
can't tell that anyone else
is privy to that conversation.
That means it can be
incredibly sneaky.
And for that reason, it's
usually very poor etiquette.
And "Debrett's" actually
covers this as well.
It says, if you
need to loop someone
in on an email conversation
confidentially,
you should forward
the email to them
with a note explaining
why it's confidential.
That way you don't get in one
of those awkward situations
where someone
doesn't realize they
were on BCC and not CC,
et cetera, et cetera.
But there are a few
situations where
BCC is not only acceptable,
but very necessary--
to protect people's identities.
So if you're emailing
a whole group of people
and you don't want
to reveal their names
and their email
addresses to each other,
email it to yourself,
and everyone else on BCC.
This is super important.
Sometimes it can even
be a legal requirement.
In 2016, there was
a London NHS clinic
that accidentally revealed the
identity of hundreds of people
who had used an HIV
clinic, because someone
forgot to put them on BCC.
So they were all sent together.
They were obviously
fined lots for that.
Hopefully, you guys aren't
doing anything quite as
sensitive as that, but
it's still useful to use.
To avoid a
reply-allpocalypse-- do you all
know what I mean if I
say a reply-allpocalypse?
AUDIENCE: Definitely.
VICTORIA TURK: Yeah.
When someone sent
an email, usually
to an office mailing
list, and they think
it's just for their department.
But it ends up being the
whole office, and also
all the global offices.
And someone replies
back and they're like--
the classic-- "take
me off this thread."
And then everyone else does, and
you end up with this huge pile
up.
So BCC-- if you're
emailing lots of people
and you want to avoid that,
it can be a useful tool.
Because all the
people who are on
BCC are not able to reply all.
They can only
reply to the person
who actually sent the email.
Another example, also
from the NHS, actually,
which apparently has some work
to do on its email skills.
They had-- if you think
reply-allpocalypses
that you've seen
have been bad, they
had one, also in 2016, that
affected the entirety of NHS
mail, and it resulted in around
500 million emails being sent,
because they were all sent to
every other person with an NHS
email address.
So yeah, it can be bad.
"To nobly save
someone else's inbox."
This is a quite
specific situation,
but it actually comes
up all the time.
So this is when someone
emails you and a colleague
with a request.
And you say, oh, you know what?
Actually, I'm better
placed to deal with this.
No need for my colleague
to be involved.
So what you should do
is respond to them,
move your colleague to BCC,
and say in the email something
to the effect of, hey, I'm
best placed to deal with this.
Moving Sally to BCC
to save her inbox.
And that means that Sally
will then no longer receive
any more emails on the thread.
So it's the ultimate act of
email self-sacrifice, right?
You're taking on that
thread and saying, actually,
you don't need to be involved.
Don't worry about it.
So that's a really
good thing to do.
OK, we're coming to
the end now, because I
think we've covered most
of the major points.
Oh, just as I was talking about
a reply-allpocalypse and using
the all-office email
address, I thought I'd end--
obviously, if you've
been paying attention,
you should be able
to work out now
that you should never really
be using an all-office email
address unless you
really have to.
The three circumstances under
which it is acceptable--
a genuine emergency, an official
announcement, and free food.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, one of those is a joke.
Can you tell which one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTORIA TURK:
Genuine emergency.
You shouldn't be
emailing in a fire.
[LAUGHS]
Thank you very much,
everyone, for listening.
My name's Victoria Turk.
"Digital Etiquette," the
book, is out this week.
That's my Twitter
handle, if you want
to tweet abuse at me later.
[LAUGHS] And I think we're
going to have some questions.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
So we do have time
for questions.
Please go to the microphone
in the middle of the room
so we can all hear you.
And while you're going there,
I have the first question
[INAUDIBLE]
VICTORIA TURK: Sure.
SPEAKER: You talked about
business email-- work email,
mostly.
Do you see any general
difference between work email
and personal email?
VICTORIA TURK: I have
to say I don't really
know that many people who
email in their personal lives
that much anymore.
Does anyone here email for fun?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTORIA TURK: A couple.
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
Obviously, the rules
are very different.
It all goes back to that context
of how formal you need to be.
If you're actually genuinely
friends with people,
you can be a lot
more freely spoken,
and you don't have to
abide by the rules so much.
I think the really
interesting thing about email,
actually, is that it
can take the place
of several different things.
It used to be very much used
like a snail mail letter.
Now it's often used more
like a text message.
And I think in
your personal life,
you're probably going to be
doing more of the latter.
But yeah, use loads of
emojis would be my advice.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: All right, so let's
start with the assumption
that all the people
in the room now
are able to draft
the perfect emails,
and send them at
the right times,
and we're all going to be good.
But how do we actually
deal with receiving emails
that are not appropriate?
How do we actually respond
to the "thanks in advance,"
the emails sent at night?
And how do we encourage
people to follow
the digital etiquette,
without sounding pretentious?
VICTORIA TURK: That's
a really good question.
Yeah, obviously it would
be quite poor etiquette
if you went off
at your colleague
for using "thanks in advance."
So there's not much
you can do on that one,
except for silently enjoy
the feeling of self-worth
you get from doing it better.
For email sent at night, I
think workplaces on the whole
should establish better codes of
conduct when it comes to email.
It is so often
this thing that is
assumed that everyone
knows how to do it
and how to do it correctly.
And actually,
expectations just vary
so widely that that's
clearly not the case.
So I think every
workplace should
have a standard set of rules
on when you're supposed
to be emailing and not.
It's really funny, isn't it?
Because we all seem to assume,
now that we have smartphones
and that we are
technically contactable
most of the time, that we
need to always be on call.
I'm a culture journalist.
There's not many
emergencies where
I'm going to be the
person that someone calls.
And yet even I'm like, oh
gosh, I've got an email.
I'd better check
it, just in case.
I don't think that's
ever been super urgent.
But it is hard to get
out of that mentality.
So I do think as
senders, you have to--
the onus to fix that is on you.
If you receive it,
obviously, if it's possible,
just don't answer it.
I think people get
different expectations
around different people based
on your behavior as well.
If they know that you're
going to answer at 11:00 PM,
because you always
do, they're probably
going to keep doing that.
Whereas if you establish that
kind of routine where actually,
I don't answer my emails
until 8:30 in the morning
or 9:00 in the
morning, then they
may end up respecting
that without you having
to actually say anything.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the talk.
So on the subject
of email sign-offs,
one option which
you didn't mention
is, how about having
no sign-off at all?
VICTORIA TURK: No sign-off.
AUDIENCE: That is
something I do sometimes,
when-- especially replying
to an existing conversation,
or a colleague I know well.
So it's faster.
VICTORIA TURK: Yeah.
I'd say that's similar to the
greeting at the beginning.
If you're having a back
and forth with someone,
you don't need to sign off.
And I often actually just
sign off with the letter V--
the first letter of my name.
And I think in that
context, that's fine.
The first email you send, I
think you do need to sign off.
Again, obviously,
if it's a more--
acting more like a letter
than a text message,
then you need to sign off.
But I don't think
there's anything rude
about having no
sign-off if you're
treating it like a
back-and-forth conversation.
I think that's fine.
AUDIENCE: Hey, thanks.
Thanks for coming.
You talked about email in
professional environments.
I'm sure that in
the book, you also
talk about personal
relationships, as you said.
Can we hear your
thoughts on what
I would call the dictatorship
of the blue tick?
Like when you send a message,
someone sees that you saw, or--
VICTORIA TURK: I have such
strong thoughts on this.
AUDIENCE: --you've watched
someone's story on Instagram,
and they're like, I know
that you've watched it,
and you didn't say anything.
And then it's like, eh.
What am I supposed
to do [INAUDIBLE]
VICTORIA TURK: Yeah.
I'm being left unread
is excruciating, right?
When you can see someone's
read your WhatsApp,
and they haven't
bothered to respond.
And you're like, but you
had time to check it.
What do I think about that?
I think you shouldn't
leave people unread.
I think we probably shouldn't
be so neurotic about it,
but I don't know
how to fix that.
I'm terrible for this.
I read so much into
those little blue ticks.
So I think-- if I relate
it back to inbox zero,
which I mentioned earlier, part
of the rules of inbox zero is
if you check your inbox--
if you check an email,
you have to have time
to do something about it.
There's no point
looking at it if you
know you're not going to be
able to do anything about it,
because then you're just going
to have to read it twice,
and you've doubled the
amount of time spent on it.
I think it would be good
to apply a similar idea
to your WhatsApp messages.
If you're checking them, you
should have time to answer.
And that way, you don't end
up leaving people unread.
And again, it could
be the same where,
if it's someone trying
to organize a dinner
and asking you lots
of dates, and you
need to check your calendar, you
can just respond like oh, I'll
check this later.
But that way, they at least know
that you've seen their message.
Because that's the thing about
the blue ticks, is we used to--
before you had them, someone
could see your message
and not respond to it.
But you wouldn't be so bothered
about it, because you just--
you could invent all
these myths about why
they hadn't responded.
Like oh, they haven't
checked their phone.
Oh, they're probably
really busy.
Oh, maybe they died in a ditch.
But when you see
the blue ticks, you
know they've actually
seen it, and that's
what's so irritating.
AUDIENCE: You acknowledged
that most of us
don't use email for
personal stuff anymore.
Do you think that's
entirely a good thing?
Or there's cases, for example,
like planning a holiday
or something--
would a WhatsApp group or an
email thread be better to that?
VICTORIA TURK: That's
an interesting question,
because I just tried
to plan a holiday
with my family over WhatsApp,
and we all fell out.
It was a disaster.
Would email have been better?
For something like that where
it involves lots of discussion,
I think the best thing is
an actual conversation.
Obviously, that isn't
always possible.
I suppose the
advantage of email is
you can include more information
and you can put links
to stuff and things like that.
Yeah, I just think--
I don't even know most my
friend's email addresses.
So I just think
it's not the kind
of go-to communication for
those more friendly situations
these days.
Maybe it should be.
Maybe we should
try to revive it.
I think maybe everyone's
so put off email,
just from work email and
it just being so terrible,
that I'm loathe to try to bring
that into my private life.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SPEAKER: Last chance
for questions.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Good talk.
Having sent email for decades,
and from a very nerdy area,
the majority of
mails I dealt with
were reply inline, with the
Chevron indentation moving.
The thread was easy to follow.
VICTORIA TURK: Oh, my god.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Outlook came
along, and the cursor
flashed at the top, and a
new generation of non-tech
started just
replying-- top posting.
And there's a different
style of email arrived.
And then you can't
mix the two at all.
Google--
I thought I'd given up
and the ship had sailed.
But at Google, it's surprising.
There's a good 40% mails
on reply inlines list.
This has still
survived as a thing,
and I just wanted to know
what your take on that was.
And how-- should I just give up?
And I'm just an old-timer,
and I should just--
or is this really--
it can lead to quite
a nice thread--
a very good, easy way to
follow what's going on.
You're replying
to specific bits.
Or-- discuss.
VICTORIA TURK: Yeah.
That's a really good
point, actually.
Because that, I think, is when
things can go really wrong,
is when you mix the two, right?
And so the thread goes
completely out of control,
and it's part chronological,
and then it skips something
and you're like, what?
I have to say, I think
most people don't even
think about this, and they
rely on the technology
to do it for them.
I don't-- I'm not sure if I have
a particular preference for one
or the other.
I think the problem
is if you're mixing.
So as soon as the thread is
established in a certain way,
you should just follow suit.
That's probably the best
answer I have on that one.
Which do you prefer?
AUDIENCE: Inline.
VICTORIA TURK: Inline.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: All right.
We are at the end.
So once again, thank you
very much, Victoria Turk.
[APPLAUSE]
VICTORIA TURK: Thank you.